[Musique]
les trois projections proposées cet
après midi sont des tests commandés par
les distributeurs pour jauger l'intérêt
du film avant sa sortie
officieusement la raison est plus
politique que marketing
c'est un cinéma n'est pas un lieu
contagieux et dangereux les gens sont
extrêmement responsables de cinéma nous
demandons l'ouverture
bonsoir ça peut être comment allez vous
très bien merci de m'avoir invité sur
twitter ce soir on est en mars 2021 et
j'ai l'impression qu'on se retrouve en
mars 2020 et ce qui est proprement
insupportable pour nos concitoyens c'est
qu'on n'ait pas tiré les leçons
depuis un an de ce qui se passe petit
confiné l'île de france le week-end ou
de façon plus large en tout cas nous
sommes sur le fil du rasoir si on écoute
jean castex chaque jour qui passe semble
confiné l'île de france c'est du temps
qu'on gagne ou c'est du temps qu'on perd
non je crois que l'idée c'est de tout
faire pour éviter un recond sinon vous
allez nous dire il faut re confiné en
fait tout dépend de la situation parce
que nous la surveillons au quotidien
cette situation allait vous l'avez noté
extrêmement évolutive je comprenais le
choix du président de la république de
ne pas tous fermés ya des millions et
des millions de français qui le
comprennent et qu'ils voient avec
angoisse
l'idée qu' on pourrait procéder à un ré
enfermement généralisée à un requin
confinement généralisé s'il est
nécessaire
comment la fire convent l'a fait avant
nous y procéderont on peut comprendre
qu'il y ait du tâtonnement
mais on ne comprend plus rien de ce que
fait le gouvernement là est ce que fait
le président de la république puisque
ils annoncent des décisions tout seul on
s'arrête un instant sur l'interview de
jean-michel blanquer requis la donne est
mise de l'éducation nationale au
parisien ce matin
l'école est la dernière chose à faire
mais voilà ce qu'il dit les réactions en
italie où le dernier jour de liberté ce
dimanche avant un recond finement dès
demain pour la majeure partie du pays a
les zones les plus peuplées notamment
les régions de milan de rome sont
concernés dès demain les bars les
restaurants referme tout comme les
écoles il ya des situations de tensions
fortes sur les hôpitaux et les services
de réanimation en ile de france et ses
transferts de patients nous permettent
de soulager le plus possible c'est
service de réanimation autre obsession
pour l'instant il tient de la verrière
envisagent tous les malades c'est de
faire en sorte oui mais il faut le dire
de façon très précise
la france n'a jamais eu à choisir entre
ces patients
contrairement à certains de nos pays nos
voisins pardon européen alors 175
nations par exemple ont été évacuées
depuis fin janvier
c'est beaucoup et 1000 patients ont
bénéficié d'une veille sanitaire depuis
le début de la pandémie donc ça vous
montre la mobilisation des moyens les
transferts vont s'intensifier dès demain
par voie aérienne d'abord puis par tgv
médicalisé en fin de semaine une
centaine de patients au total pour
soulager des hôpitaux proches de la
saturation
le groupe pharmaceutique anglo-suédois
prévoyait la livraison de 300 millions
de doses pour la période décembre juin
2021 des prévisions revues bien à la
baisse depuis
c'est désormais seulement 100 millions
de doses qui sont promises avant fin
juin puis des effets secondaires
concernant la coagulation lui sont
également imputés l'irlande vient
d'ailleurs à son tour de recommander la
suspension de ce vaccin comme l'ont fait
d'autres pays
auparavant la france quant à elle
continue d'utiliser et se veut
rassurante
j'ai traversé paris dans des cortèges
toutes sirènes hurlantes et cetera
oublier ça on n'oublie pas mais c'est
pas la vie c'est pas ça la vie celui qui
pense que c'est ça la vie les malheureux
après un cas positif au gouvernement la
ministre du travail elisabeth bornes
malgré quelques symptômes je me porte
bien écrit-elle sur twitter les rangs
politiques
non je crois pas toujours se méfier jour
qui dit je ne serai plus jamais comme
videur